20h45 sur figaro live bonsoir à toutes
et à tous bienvenue dans ce direct et
cette mise en place du couvre feu en
région ile de france et dans huit
métropoles françaises on va vivre cet
événement ce nouvel événement de 2020 au
sein de cette crise sanitaire on va le
vivre ensemble un couvre-feu qui débute
dans quatorze minutes précisément à 21h
il va durer jusqu'à six heures du matin
et ce pour quatre semaines
au moins on est en live avec vous sur
lefigaro.fr évidemment sur nos chaînes
youtube et twitch aussi on va prendre
vos questions si vous n'êtes pas tout
compris aux attestations par exemple à
l'éventuelle tolérance aux dérogations
alors ça c'est non a répété jean castex
il ya quelques jours en direct de lille
concernant notamment le monde de la
culture et bien vous nous mais poser ses
questions et vous nous envoyez vos
réactions également je vois qui a d'ores
et déjà une réaction sur notre chaîne
youtube avec ferdinand
vous nous dites n'importe quoi le
couvre-feu on va en débattre on est là
pour débattre également et antoine qui
nous demandent quels seront les invités
parce qu'évidemment il ya dans cette
soirée spéciale sur figaro live des
invités qu'on va retrouver dans quelques
instants pour vous faire vivre ce début
du couvre-feu et puis pour mesurer les
conséquences sociales sociétales et
économiques on sera dans quelques
instants avec yann bastière qui est le
délégué national du syndicat unité sgp
police force ouvrière unité sgp police
fo
on sera quelques minutes plus tard avec
sylvain châtelain un rédacteur en chef
figaro live qui sera dans le nord de la
capitale pour voir tout juste après 21h
voir si ce couvre feu et est bien
respectée vous voyez en direct un des
champs elysées on s'arrête sur ces
images les grilles du magasin monoprix
qui sont en train d'être fermés un les
restaurants les commerces de bouche et
commerciaux vêtements également entre
autres pour ne citer qu'eux sont en
train de fermer commerce qu'on trouve
comme ceux magasins foot locker par
exemple sur les champs elysées un peu
plus tard vers 21h15 on mesurera les les
conséquences économiques pour le secteur
de l'hôtellerie-restauration nous serons
avec laurent duc qui est le président de
la branche hôtellerie de l'umih
et puis on retrouvera
à nouveau sylvain châtelain un peu plus
tard aux alentours de 21h 30 nous sommes
en direct de paris
vous le voyez les champs elysées on va
aller prendre le pouls également du côté
de lyon on bascule en temps réel grâce à
julien qu'une aile à la réalisation que
je salue et que je remercie vous voyez
l'hôtel de ville place des terreaux en
ce moment du côté de lyon pas mal de
personnes encore qu'ils sont en train de
marcher à vélo à pied en trottinette
on sera de se déplacer très certainement
on leur souhaite un vers leur domicile
puisque dans une dizaine de minutes
et bien si on n'a pas une raison valable
de se déplacer ce sera une amende de 135
euros alors il ya cette attestation que
vous pouvez télécharger on va vous la
mettre dans le chatt attestation de
déplacement dérogatoire je vous la
montre que vous pouvez retrouver sur
lefigaro.fr vous pouvez indiquer vos nom
prénom adresse et le motif de votre
déplacement par exemple bien pour aller
faire faire les besoins à votre animal
de compagnie par exemple je passe dans
le chat pour vous saluer pour prendre
des premières questions et réactions
bienvenue sur youtube je vois zazou je
vois hélène
vous dites que on dirait que ça ne vous
fait plaisir alors non je vais vous dire
très honnêtement ça ne me fait pas
plaisir de travailler un samedi soir je
vais être totalement transparent avec
vous mais par contre ce qui me fait
plaisir c'est de vivre ensemble cette
actualité une actualité importante et et
de mesurer justement les conséquences
que tout cela va avoir sur notre
quotidien dans les prochaines semaines
en tout cas le quotidien de 20 millions
de personnes pour l'instant 20 millions
d'habitants en ile-de-france et dans les
métropoles de lille rouen lyon grenoble
saint-etienne montpellier toulouse et
aix marseille
je vous le disais en introduction
premiers invités de cette soirée yann
bastière qu'on va retrouver tout de
suite en liaison par skype vont soir
yann bastière bonsoir vous êtes donc je
le disais le délégué national du
syndicat unité sgp police force ouvrière
se sont donc vos collègues qui vont être
déployés dans les différentes villes et
régions qu'on a cité juste avant je
précise que vous situer en ce moment du
côté de montpellier alors on va faire un
focus sur montpellier mais aussi sur les
autres métropoles et la région
ile-de-france qui sont je le disais
concernait pas ce couvre-feu première
réaction pour vous est-ce que entre le
les sept cette interview d'emmanuel
macro mercredi et ce soir est ce que du
côté de vos collègues
la mise en place a été fluide ou est ce
qu'au contraire ça s'annonce un petit
peu compliqué on va être entre les deux
il fuit ni compliqué parce que nous
sommes confrontés a juste à une
adaptation du confinement plus globale
que nous avions connu au printemps
donc là on va leur porter ce dispositif
avec le contrôle des attestations
uniquement sur les nuits entre 21h et 6h
donc pas habitués mais on va s'adapter à
ce nouveau système métier qui est un peu
plus atypique parce qu'ils à ce passé
que la nuit donc non je ne suis assez
confiant pour mes collègues on va
prendre un exemple concret et yann
bastière vous êtes à montpellier nous
avec julien la réalisation n'est du côté
de paris xi imaginons dans 20 minutes
bon on a un petit peu traîné on a eu un
retard de métro on n'a donc pas
d'attestation dérogatoire et on tombe
sur vos collègues
est-ce que
on s'expose d'ores et déjà à une amende
alors ça oui mais est-ce qu'on va en
avoir une ou est ce que bon ce soir le
premier week-end et un petit peu de
tolérance quelles ont été les consignes
transmises vers vous l'avait bien dit
les consignes à les consignes sur est
claire ce pourrait être la verbalisation
immédiate mais je fais entièrement
confiance à mes collègues à leur force
de jugement et à leur libre arbitre
on est samedi soir c'est l'entrée en
vigueur de ce couvre-feu dans les
grandes métropoles françaises dans
montpellier dont paris lille lyon
je pense qu'on va rester dans un premier
temps sur du pédagogique sur comme si
elle avait pu se faire effectivement au
printemps les cas extrêmes où là on
tomberait sur des hurluberlus des bières
humaine qui voudraient rien entendre et
vous ça dégénère dans la mobilisation
est tout à fait possible mais dans votre
cas si effectivement vous étiez un peu
en retard à la sortie du métro
je pense que mes collègues vous
rappellerai les conditions du moment
mais ça ne voudrait pas plus loin
alors on arrive à une question très
importante une question stratégique
évidemment qui nous vient du figaro.fr
c'est aigle ou que je salue que nous a
rejoint les policiers ont-ils les moyens
de faire respecter ce couvre feu les
moyens c'est très compliqué
effectivement là nous allons tomber
effectivement sur la période nocturne le
manque d'effectifs et criant et nous
l'avons rappelé au président de la
république et au ministre cette semaine
et notamment la nuit notamment la nuit
les effectifs sont contraints alors
peut-être pas sur une métropole comme
paris et met sur la banlieue parisienne
sur des métropoles comme montpellier je
connais les effectifs contre un sur sept
cette ville sur la circonscription de
sécurité publique ça va être une
commande il ya une petite petite
complexité supplémentaire
c'est à dire que les patrouilles ils
vont devoir se rajouter ça alors que et
de surcroît nous sommes sur des vacances
scolaires mes collègues ont le droit de
souffler et de faire baisser la charge
mentale en famille donc voilà on a cette
complexité du moment tu pas facile à
gérer
du côté de montpellier arrêtons-nous sur
l'exemple de la capitale héraultaise est
ce qui a eu un renforcement d'effectifs
absolument pas alors je vous dis
absolument pas dernièrement notre notre
organisation syndicale appuyés par des
parlementaires et le maire de
montpellier comme ça puisse se faire
dans d'autres métropoles de france sont
allés taper à la porte de monsieur
d'arman notre ministre de tutelle pour
demander des effectifs est la première
mesure d'urgence
ça a été effectivement d'envoyer une
demi compagnie de crs tout les soirs de
week-end donc ce soir encore ils seront
sur montpellier
mais ça ne va pas se retrouver sur les
autres métropoles de france spécialement
et puis à la wii non non je vous en prie
et puis on le sait un les forces de
l'ordre avec les événements à qui se
sont succédé ces dernières années les
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites les gilets jaunes sont une
charge physique et mentale qui est assez
importante dans vos rangs est ce que est
ce que cette usure physique et peut-être
surtout mental vous en parlez entre vous
est ce que c'est un sujet qui est
prépondérant ce moment il est quotidien
depuis de nombreuses années je veux pas
vous parler et nous en avoir parlé ces
dernières heures de 2015
mais dès 2015 avec les différents les
différents attentats et depuis les
vigipirate et vigipirate renforcé et
gilet jaune ce contexte qu vide très
lourd
les effectifs de police sont épuisés le
contexte de violence à l'encontre des
forces de l'ordre
le week-end dernier champigny sur marne
à des tirs de mortiers
quelques jours auparavant non collègues
de l'antenne de police judiciaire de
cergy pontoise froidement froidement
sorti d'une voiture j'ai à dire abattu
heureusement ils sont encore parmi nous
mais voilà il ya un contexte est très
très lourd au sein des forces de l'ordre
et se couvre feu sans apporter sans
apporter de complexité supplémentaire
vers a mené une charge de travail
notoire ça c'est sans aucun doute ils
s'organisent
justement comment vous voyez les choses
c'est quoi cette charge de travail
supplémentaire le contrôle ni plus ni
moins le contrôle de ces attestations
qu'elles soient physiques sur une du
papier ou par le support électronique
sur les téléphones cc c'est une charge
supplémentaire une toute façon si c'est
ce que vous faites est mis en place et
leur clique soient respectées et nous
sommes là tout comme nos collègues
gendarmes sur certaines zones pour le
faire respecter
une question intéressante qui nous vient
du figaro.fr skywalker qui nous parle de
cet horaire 21h pourquoi est ce que on
l'est on l'avait dit juste avant
l'interview d'emmanuel macro que l'heure
du début du couvre feu pouvait avoir une
incidence sur évidemment le secteur
économique l'hôtellerie restauration
mais est ce que justement dans vos rangs
du côté de la police est ce que leur a
une incidence est ce que 21h c'est très
différent pour vous que 20 heures ou 22
heures par exemple pas réellement pas
réellement 21h06 heures c'est l'heure ce
qu'on pourrait dire de sûreté vue de vue
des heures de perquisition voilà entre
21h et 6h par exemple ne pouvons pas
positionné librement dans un domicile
voilà est-ce que cette heure a été fixé
comme ça je ne sais pas non ça ne vous
posera pas plus de problèmes que ça 20h
sera été réellement très tôt par rapport
aux équipements au tissu économique
les magasins qui sont en train de fermer
des gens il y au dernier moment où
débauche en en voile à 21h on est déjà
sur un sur un créneau beaucoup plus
beaucoup d adapter pour du contrôle à 22
heures soirée était certainement plus
intéressant pour le tissu économique
comme les restaurants les bars le
problème se pose plus depuis quelques
jours déjà sur vos moyens d'intervention
le sien à montpellier comme dans dents
la plupart des autres villes concernées
par le couvre-feu il y a des quartiers
sensibles
est ce que vous êtes organisé ce que ça
fait l'objet d'une organisation
particulière
les modalités d'intervention en cas de
non respect dans ces quartiers et zones
sensibles
mes collègues plus vigilants comme je
vous dis les violences dont nous avons
été nous allons été victime ce contexte
terroristes qui rejaillit aujourd'hui
mais par ailleurs non nous avons connu
nous avons connu dès le printemps avec
avec la rue de confinement complète déjà
des des problèmes pour faire respecter
ce confinement
rien qu'en journée sur les courtiers des
quartiers compliquée et sensible je sais
pas parler de zones de non droit à mes
collègues tentent tant bien que mal de
faire respecter les textes dans ces
zones là non il n'y a pas vraiment une
de dispositif particulier sur ça mais on
sait compte c'est la complexité que ça
va être de faire respecter sa et l
esprit civique sur certains endroits ce
sera compliqué à faire respecter
effectivement il ya également évidemment
on l'a vu hier avec cet attentat
terrible à conflans sainte honorine il
ya là la menace terroriste qui ressurgit
en tout cas qui est plus visible
qu'auparavant et cette résurgence elle
arrive en même temps que cette deuxième
vague et ces nouvelles mesures ces
mesures fortes les deux percute et
j'imagine que pour vous ça va être peu
évident à gérer se percutent et je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas qui percute qui
ce drame d'hier soir est tout simplement
effroyable mais dans la tête depuis
nombreuses années comme je voulais
évoquer tout à l'heure dans la tête de
tous mes collègues fonctionnaires
cette menace terroriste allez allez la
teinte on sait qu'on vit avec on l'a
réactive peut-être de temps en temps
enfin ça d'être des bras mais des actes
de barbarie comme on a pu les voir hier
soir mais effectivement effectivement
ben voilà comme vous dites ça vient
percuter ça vient réactiver cette
sensibilité entité rocke chacun de mes
collègues intègre maintenant dans leur
quotidien que ce soit des collègues sur
des services d'élite comme on peut le
voir sur des interventions aussi bien
que sur les premiers les primes aux
intervenants comme ça a été le cas hier
soir
si on met collègues sont abattues ce
terroriste en pleine rue donc on a ça
qui serait actif et puis comme vous
dites on a quand même
ce couvre-feu où il va falloir à faire
entendre raison à certaines personnes ou
ce sera certainement très compliqué si
vous aviez un message à transmettre au
ministre de l'intérieur au président de
la république bat les syndicats vos
syndicats ont été reçus
c'était jeudi par emmanuel macron mais
s'il y avait un message sur le il
fallait appuyer ce serait quoi les
hausses d'effectifs qu'est ce que vous
réclamez nombreux feux de bonnes
manières à par rapport aux les effectifs
y sont là sur cette période de six
semaines les effectifs on ne va pas les
inventer ne vont pas sortir d'école ne
vont pas être affectés dans les services
donc il va falloir faire avec les moyens
du bord il va falloir qu'on s'adapte à
cette petite surcharge de travail
supplémentaire et que mes collègues
intègre totalement nous sommes quand
même là dans une crise sanitaire c'est
pour le bien être de tout le monde
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
l'urgence ce nous allons faire avec
si j'ose dire les moyens du bord en
effectif ça sera pas plus en véhicule ça
ne sera pas plus on est on est face à un
nouveau dispositif
on s'adapte c'est un peu la force de des
forces de l'ordre
si je prends reprend à nouveau l'exemple
de montpellier selon vous pour affronter
cette période ces quatre semaines mais
ont cédé quasiment
davant ce sera six semaines de couvre
feu selon vous il faudrait combien de
policiers en plus alors là vous devenez
sur sur une thématique qui est qui
montrent que l'iran ne purent nous
réclamant une trentaine de policiers
rien que pour faire fonctionner à peu
près d'un service c'est une première
chose c'est ce qui a été demandé par les
élus
dernièrement à notre ministre de
l'intérieur donc ils seraient ils y
seraient les bienvenues mais pour la
police du quotidien sauf qu'il ne faut
surtout pas
je me permets de l'évoquer la négliger
le continuum de sécurité et se passer de
nos collègues de la police municipale
certes les effectifs sont plus
contraints mais ils doivent ils doivent
elles doivent s'est il participe
pleinement au respect de ce couvre-feu
sur sur les grandes agglomérations
parisienne
on peut lier les grandes villes que nous
avons cités sont dotés de police
municipale donc ce continuum de sécurité
doit fonctionner est aujourd'hui bien
même si dans toutes ces villes là
ces polices municipales ne sont pas là
la nuit il faudrait peut-être que quand
décale ça il faudrait qu'ils viennent
nous prêter main forte sur cette période
en plus comme je dis nous sommes sur une
période de congés scolaires ou les
collègues endroit souffler un petit peu
et donc ce continuum de sécurité avec ce
mixage police nationale police
municipale sur cette période
21h06 heures serait la bienvenue quelles
ont été les consignes transmises par par
la préfecture
notamment ces derniers jours on va dire
d'appliquer si ce n'est voilà où le plus
pas le plus fermement
mais bien sûr que les préfet ne peuvent
pas on peut pas plaisanter là on est pas
on n'est pas à rigoler on a une deuxième
vague qui sans devraient déferler
voilà il faut appliquer la loi comme
vous l'avez dit peut-être que ce soit on
va être sur une certaine une certaine
souplesse une certaine pédagogie mais ça
ne va pas durer indéfiniment
nous sommes sereins sur une sur une
séquence de quatre à six semaines
espérons qu'elle ne dure pas plus et que
les chiffres s'inverse mais très
rapidement effectivement ça va être
l'application stricte du texte et les
135 euros et les 1500 euros en cas de
récidive
merci beaucoup yann bastière d'avoir été
avec nous font rire
pour cette entrée en vigueur cette
première soirée sous couvre feu depuis
trois minutes un désormais dans huit
métropoles ainsi que la région ile de
france je rappelle que vous êtes délégué
national du syndicat unité sgp police fo
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec lyon je
rappelle que vous envoyiez bien en
direct de montpellier
un petit tour dans les différents chat
pour voir les questions que vous vous
posez et que vous nous posez sur
lefigaro.fr sur youtube et sur twitch
bonsoir dany bon soir kriss kross
bonsoir avec respect qui est avec nous
également sur la home à vous avez vu les
questions de la homepage on les a
relayés en direct à yann bastière dans
un instant on va aller dans le nord de
la capitale là on s'arrête sur ces
images des abords de l'hôtel de ville de
lyon place des terreaux c'est à lyon que
nous irons retrouver tout à l'heure
laurent duc président de la branche
hôtellerie du l'umih de l'umih du
syndicat umih un petit tour aussi du
côté de paris on va vous montrer grâce à
nos confrères de la fp ce qui se passe
tiens justement les forces de l'ordre
déployées vous allez voir en direct une
discussion une première discussion sur
les champs elysées entre des forces de
l'ordre et
des consommateurs qui sortent des
restaurants qui sont désormais fermés
vous voyez que les l'avenue est en train
de déserter d'être désertés par les
dernières personnes qui étaient en train
de marcher toujours remontre aussi
l'attestation couvre-feu tout à l'heure
on sait pas la bonne attestation qu'on
avait montré on vous remonte l'article
sur lefigaro.fr vous pouvez taper un
attestation couvre-feu le figaro sur
google et vous allez tomber sur
l'article qui vous donne le lien article
de benjamin ferran qui vous donne le
lien pour retrouver cette attestation
vous pouvez cliquer voilà on peut la
télécharger en direct on vous met aussi
le lien pour l'attestation smartphones
et on va la découvrir en direct cette
attestation je disais tout à l'heure on
ça ça change pas par rapport au
printemps
vous mettez votre nom prénom votre date
de naissance là où vous habitez et puis
vous voyez parmi les motifs alors c'est
un langage un peu précis mais enfin en
gros c'est les déplacements entre le
domicile et le travail
les consultations de soins urgente on
imagine que vous n'avez pas à les
consulter votre généraliste à 21h mais
en tout cas s'il ya une urgence
s'il faut aller à l'hôpital ou autre
vous cochez cette case
le motif familial impérieux les
personnes en situation de handicap et
leurs accompagnants convocations
judiciaires ou administratives
les missions d'intérêt général sans
jamais ça au printemps aussi et puis
aussi les déplacements bref dans un
rayon maximal d'un kilomètre autour du
domicile pour les besoins des animaux de
compagnie vous d'été vous signez et
voilà le formulaire que vous devez
montrer sous forme papier écrite par
vote mans aussi de votre main ou sur
smartphone en cas de contrôle
bonsoir nathan sur lefigaro.fr merci
d'être avec nous zazou qui nous dit sur
youtube le couvre feu va tuer les
restaurants les bars etc
on va justement pouvoir relayer vos
questions sur ce domaine en particulier
à laurent duc dans quelques minutes
21h c'est sévère nous dit franklin et
west franklin mais apparemment vous
n'habitez pas en france et vous nous
demandez les horaires de notre couvre
feu c'est 21h06 heures et ça concerne
donc l'île de france ainsi que huit
métropoles dont lyon marseille grenoble
ou encore saint-etienne un petit tour du
côté de notre chaîne twitch ou the
phoenix nous a rejoint le zivan serein
t-il couvert par figaro live nous
demande nerf de la guerre alors non
cette année nous ne sommes pas du côté
deuxième vingt puisque vous l'avez sans
doute suivi mais la mise en place de cet
événement a été très très compliqué et
semé d'embûches et on imagine que
rajouter une horde de médias n'auraient
pas forcément aidé zerator et ses amis
en tout cas on vous souhaite un bon
visionnage si vous regarder l'événement
en direct
bonsoir fanch bonsoir isabelle bonsoir
bouadjadj à sur youtube merci d'être
avec nous poser nouveau questions dites
mais aussi ce qui se passe autour de
chez vous que vous soyez ou pas sous
couvre-feu je vois un internaute c'est
dany qui nous narguent un petit peu sur
la home qui nous dit il est 21h je
m'apprête avec mon épouse allait dîner
au resto parce que dany bas il n'est pas
en couvre feu et ben bon vous souhaite
un bon dîner en tout cas un dernier on
vous souhaite
et bien que le couvre-feu ne s'applique
pas dans votre ville dans les semaines
qui viennent ce qui signifiera que les
les indicateurs ne sont jamais dire sont
plutôt bons en fait ne sont pas trop
mauvais en tout cas je vais vous
dévoiler le nombre de nouveaux cas qui
ont été qui a été relevé en france par
santé public français ces dernières
heures c'est vrai que les indicateurs
sont sont vraiment dans le rouge
on va vous voyez sur ces images qu'on
est en direct des champs elysées on va
prendre tout de suite la direction en
bas du nord de la capitale le xviiie
arrondissement c'est là où nous attend
sylvain châtelain rédacteur en chef
figaro live bonsoir sylvain alors m'a
dit que vous êtes et ce qui se passe
autour de vous un ce qu'on entend ce
qu'on peut voir tout simplement bizarre
car je suis place michel petrucciani à
paris dans le 18e arrondissement dans le
nord de la capitale
je suis sur cette place où il y a quand
même fait le voir autour de moi bien
plusieurs bars restaurants cafés qui
viennent de fermer il ya quelques
minutes ça s'est passé très rapidement
les restaure les restaurateurs les
cavités ont fermé vraiment en quatrième
vitesse les clients sont partis je vous
assure qu'il ya encore vraiment moins de
dix minutes la place était été remplies
et jeu
suis également fier avec farid que vous
voyez à côté de moi pas restée le patro
bonsoir paris qui est le patron de ce
restaurant que vous voyez juste ici je
vais vous la fiche face à face à noah et
donc je disais paraît que vous avez dû
fermer ce soir vraiment à la dernière
minute mais vous allez respecter louable
nos clients que l'otan est hantée qui le
prennent très bien ils vont tous compris
que c'était pour bientôt
on se plie en train de me disait quand
même que c'est pas facile du tout cette
période pas facile pour vous qui
s'annonce
sincèrement l'économie pour profiter des
derniers de douceur parce que là
normalement à cette heure si vous avez
combien de clients à peu près à ce qu'on
voit c'est alors comment vous envisagez
de tenir du coup d'envoi descendre
d'observation une semaine comme ça enfin
leur courage parfois comme un compliment
inévitable mais non c'est pas du tout 18
heures
que la semaine la semaine j'ai un
travail de soutien des gens pareils pas
on va observer on va regarder on va et
on va corriger si vous pensez qu'il va y
avoir un report de votre clientèle sur
plus tôt dans la journée après midi ça
paraît compliqué parce que je travaille
mais peut-être en fin d'après midi je
sais pas ce que vous prévoyez quelques
aménagements des choses des gens qu'on a
mangé plus tôt et risqué tenir en france
c'est le coût du travail
on repasse permettre d'avoir sans faux
pas voilà pierre
vous avez entendu la réaction de deux
farines pour ce premier soin d'eux le
couvre-feu je vous propose qu'on se
retrouve un petit peu plus tard durant
durant ce salon va continuer à affronter
un peu les rues de la capitale pour voir
comment s'est déroulé ce confinement
j'en veux dire que pour le moment nous
n'avons pas encore trois et deux
patrouilles de police par exemple
j'étais hier soir également un petit peu
tard dans la nuit
nous avons véritablement commencé hier
soir et j'en ai croisé quelques unes là
pour le moment ici dans ce quartier il y
en a pas mais il faut dire que
globalement le couvre-feu l'horaire de
couvre-feu a été strictement respecté
donc
donc ce n'est pas très étonnant qu'hier
merci beaucoup sylvain a tout à leur
rédacteur en chef figaro live on va vous
retrouver dans une petite demi-heure
aller pour faire un nouveau point en
tout cas on voit autour de vous un que
et vous ne vous l'avais dit que les
grilles se sont baissés d'un coup on va
retourner sur l'avenue des champs
elysées à paris rien de forcément très
étonnant à ce que on voit encore un peu
d'activité sur ce qu'on appelle la plus
belle avenue du monde
je salue kieffer 35 qui nous écrit perso
si à une urgence je me prends pas la
tête à télécharger imprimer remplir
l'attestation vous nous dites la seule
solution qui a fait ses preuves c'est le
confinement total à caen son retour
justement
les mesures qui sont prises uns les unes
après les autres sont destinées à éviter
un recond finement total le nombre de
cas le nombre de cas aujourd'hui santé
publique france nous rapporte plus de
32000 400 nouveaux cas ces dernières 24
heures sachant qu'on avait déjà un bilan
de plus de 25 mille nouveaux cas hier
vendredi
ce qui montre qu'effectivement on a une
nette accélération de la circulation en
tout cas une nette augmentation de la
positivité des tests et on espère
évidemment que le couvre feu va
permettre de faire drastiquement chuté
ces mauvais chiffres
un petit tour toujours du côté de alors
on va passer à lyon voilà on est à lyon
devant l'hôtel de ville 1 place des
terreaux vous voyez que là aussi et bien
et les chaises et les temps d'un des
différents commerces de bouche ont
disparu alors il ya quand même des
groupes de personnes qui sont en train
de marcher des groupes ou des personnes
qui travaillent et qui marche tout seul
sur sur cette place en tout cas
évidemment on constate tout de suite si
vous voyez un camion de de gendarmerie
qui est en train
d'arrivée pour patrouiller évidemment on
voit tout de suite
évidemment que c'est une activité
inhabituelle pour un samedi 21h 21h14
du côté de la capitale des gaules dans
quelques instants justement à lyon sera
avec laurent duc qui est président de la
branche hôtellerie de l'umih avant ça je
prends quelques commentaires alors
nathan vous nous dites
excusez moi le fig le sujet du jour
c'est pas le couvre feu c'est l'islam en
france aurait coûté merci de nous faire
partager votre avis sachez que demain
justement on sera en direct à 15h au
rassemblement place de la république à
paris à l'appel de charlie hebdo en
hommage à samuel le professeur de
collège qui a été sauvagement assassinée
hier à conflans sainte honorine
l'agresseur a été abattu d'ailleurs vous
avez pu suivre la conférence de presse
du procureur ricard procureur national
anti terroriste vous avez pu la suivre
un peu plus tôt sur figaro live mais
tous les sujets d'actualité sont traités
sur figaro live et demain nous serons
donc place de la république pour suivre
ce rassemblement n'hésitez pas être
présent avec nous sur lefigaro.fr on
sera également sur youtube
bonsoir également à
avec respect bonsoir à christian qui est
avec nous sur la pêche du figaro bonsoir
à jo et qui hélas sûr sur youtube merci
d'être d'être avec nous on va basculer
dans quelques instants avec laurent duc
qui est président de la jolie disait de
la branche hôtellerie de l'umih je vais
demander à julien en régie si tout est
prêt avec
notre invité dans une petite minute bon
écoutez bah moi ça me permet de
continuer à vous dire bonsoir et de
prendre des nouvelles dans le chatt
comment ça va bonsoir iam une superbe
série sur netflix l'autre côté elle
résume bien notre société dans quelques
années m'a écouté merci beaucoup
iam iam ou l'âme alors sais pas si c'est
un i majuscule loin elle merci de ce
petit conseil si comme iam vous avez des
conseils série parce que c'est vrai que
si on est concerné par le couvre feu il
va falloir s'occuper
n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas à nous
donner des conseils dans le chat si vous
êtes amateurs de tintin il ya aussi tous
les est un teint qui sont disponibles
sur sur netflix mais effectivement on va
passer des soirées automnales et
hivernales à s'occuper ailleurs que dans
des restos dans des bars et on va faire
le point sur les conséquences
économiques
dans un instant vous nous parlez de
neymar ou cr7 minox on va pouvoir parler
rapidement des résultats de ligue 1
puisqu'il ya un match en cours ce soir
marseille qui mène 1 0 contre bordeaux
dites nous ce que vous regardez comment
vous occuper ce soir en cette première
soirée de couvre feu je vois notre
deuxième invité qui est qui est présent
et qui se trouve justement dans cette
ville que vous voyez à l'image lyon
c'est laurent duc qui est le président
de la branche hôtellerie de l'umih qu'on
va tout de suite retrouvé bonsoir
laurent merci d'être avec nous alors on
avait je vais tout de suite reprendre
l'un des messages de
notre internaute à zhouqu était avec
nous sur qui toujours avec nos sur
youtube
ce couvre feu va tuer les restaurants
les bars etc on a vu il ya quelques
instants en direct les restaurateurs sur
la place des terreaux à lyon ranger les
terrasses est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce commentaire de notre internaute
alors je suis d'accord sûr qu'on va tuer
une grosse partie de la branche
on a aujourd'hui un tiers des
restaurateurs qui passeront pas le
printemps restaurateurs hôteliers cafés
je parle pas des boîtes de nuit qui
elles sont pas du tout ouverte depuis le
17 mars
un tiers des restaurateurs qui ne
passeront pas le printemps selon vous
seul un pour l'euro nous au niveau
national je pense qu'au niveau national
déjà malheureux il est clair qu'il ya
des opportunités de vacances dans des
lieux qui n'ait été moins habituels qui
sont d'une station climatique la
campagne la passe montagne et ses drames
et ça nous unit rondelle fait pas le
printemps c'est pas parce que l'été
s'est bien passée que le reste de
l'année va couvrir les frais aujourd'hui
nos frais sont les mêmes on a les mêmes
loyers les mêmes assurances les mêmes
abonnements téléphoniques et on a sur la
france pour l'hôtellerie 20% et si je
prends les restaurants de lyon il soit
descendu à moins de 40% de leur chiffre
d'affaires en n'ayant plus le service du
soir ballon
des hôtels vous en parlait il ya un
instant puisque vous êtes président de
la branche hôtellerie au sein de l'umih
c'est vrai que les autres on parle moins
des hôtels que des cafés des restaurants
des bars quelle est la conséquence de
cette mesure
ce couvre feu pour les hôtels le
problème des otages depuis le début de
ce confinement à part quelques zones qui
ont été mises en en arrêté administratif
nous sommes toujours ouverts sans client
mais toujours ouverts donc on échappe à
tous les radars on échappe les
assurances qui veulent pas payer de
terre d'exploitation lé montant de sa
résonne m'avoue en fait j'ai un retour
de grands frères les donc je reprends
lit les assurances qu'ils nous payent
pas les mesures d'accompagnement des
entrepreneurs qui ne fonctionne pas pour
les hôtels parce qu'on est
principalement dans des holding
familiale qui détient à 100% au parent
et donc comme c'est pas la holding qui
elle perd du chiffre d'affaires pour
l'instant puisque c'est décalé et bien
on n'est pas éligible aux ailes enfin
j'en passe des pires et des meilleurs le
le patrimoine hôtelier français perd 20
% de sa clientèle internationale
le haut de gamme va énormément souffrir
est-ce que suite à l' annonce des
manuels macro mercredi dans son
interview 1
l'annnonce de ce couvre-feu est ce que
on a constaté au sein des hôtels
concernés par ce couvre-feu une chute
des réservations immédiate immédiat 3
j'avais un petit portefeuille à hauteur
de 30% pour ce week-end je suis descendu
à 20 bon sens peut-être que je ferai un
peu le passage parce que effectivement
les gens ne pouvant pas sentir ou se
déplacer mais du coup il reste un petit
peu où ils viennent à l'hôtel parce que
ils peuvent encore consommée dans leur
chambre
à cet égard la mesure est
incompréhensible on nous parle de room
service dans nos hôtels tout le monde
sait que dans les hôtels 2 et 3 étoiles
il ya toujours un room service bien sûr
que l'on n'a déjà dû personne du mal à
maintenir le personnel par les hôtels on
peut servir au bar ou au restaurant nos
établissements préfèrent du room service
dans un hôtel deux étoiles trois étoiles
de plus on aura de moins en moins dans
les champs des clients dans son présent
à cause du coc vide
donc c'est une utopie on transforme aux
hôtels en prison les gens arrivent ils
s'enferment dans leur chambre
c'est insupportable en gros
concrètement moi je suis touristes
c'est pas très sexy c'est pas très
attirant quoi en ce moment ces zones
sous couvre-feu concernant les nuitées
d'hôtel quoi imaginez vous arrivé à lyon
à 22 à côté gérer parce qu'il a toujours
22 heures les avions aussi vous avez
bien prévu d'avoir dans votre valise des
poireaux des carottes et des patates et
vous les ferez cuire à la bouilloire de
la chambre de l'hôtel
c'est la seule solution pour manger je
plaisante il ya du lié à la livraison
aussi et on peut assurer de fait les
gens plus en vente est râlant chambre
mais qu'elle elle triste les aujourd'hui
dans le couvre-feu n'en pose pas aux
gens chez eux de manger dans leur
chambre ils vont au moins manger de la
cuisine la salle à manger
il vient aujourd'hui les hôtels on est
encore une fois de plus au bout de la
chaîne
ce qui ferait alors il ya des hôtels qui
ont des restaurants
une caisse qui est ce qu'ils ont droit
de rester ouverts après 21h les
restaurants des hôtels
si j'en crois le décret du président de
la république non la réalité plutôt
autres moi je suis désolé aujourd'hui
faire du room service et est ce que
j'exprime c'est impossible et et ça rend
notre établissement en dortoir et on
perd toute âme quoi donc d un mois jeudi
qu' ils ont qu'à ferron leur âme et
conscience et on veut gommer toute la
profession alors comprise ont donc fait
comme vous sentez de devoir recevoir
prions tout à l'heure vous avez abordé
un les mécanismes dead set non prise en
charge des pertes d'exploitation par les
assureurs c'est un an les les hôtels les
baisses de loyer qui est pas tout
simplement
quelles sont les solutions à l'heure
actuelle c'est d'emprunter de coups de
faire des prêts garantis par l'état
alors aujourd'hui on propose et dieu
soit loué regarde les compétences de
pouvoir mettre nos personnels au chômage
partiel savent c'est parfait pour nos
personnels mais les entreprises elles
sont vivantes j'ai oublié de l'histoire
parce que aujourd'hui on nous propose
d'emprunter de l'argent pour le
rembourser dans un an deux ans trois ans
cinq ans et longtemps qu'il faut
emprunter pour six mois de jeu pense
qu'on va aller avec une année entière de
disette vont paupérisée complètement la
capacité d'investir de nos hôtels dans
les années à venir parce qu'on va
rembourser notre dette
c'est une année entière c'est énorme
c'est la moitié ou le tiers de la valeur
de l'achat d'un fonds de commerce
donc on peut pas faire ça c'est par ici
si vous avez des question pour laurent
duc 1 le président de la branche
hôtellerie de l'umih
n'hésitez pas en et en direct sur
lefigaro.fr sur twitch sûr
facebook merci en tout cas d'être d'être
toujours présent avec nous ce qui a eu
quand même des deux nouvelles annonces
des précisions apportées notamment par
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
et des finances est-ce qu'ils ont été de
nature à vous rassurer
à
à vous apporter des aides
supplémentaires ou c'est tout le
contraire
alors la lenteur de la mise en place du
système
alors ces bonnes intentions elles
correspondent pompeux pour partie à nos
demandes
aujourd'hui la mise en action de ces
aides et le la technocratie derrière de
l'état fait que depuis le 17 mars il ya
beaucoup de choses ont été annoncées et
tous n'arrivent pas jusqu'au bout je
prends le cas des assurances je prends
que tu as des loyers aujourd'hui les
bailleurs sociaux touchant les bailleurs
en général pas ce sur projets initiaux
les bailleurs touche à 100% lors lors
leur loyer nous on exerce à moins de 30%
donc un une dysphasie total dans la
valeur du début loyer et dans la
capacité des entreprises à payer quand
l'entreprise payer un loyer qui pourrait
correspondre d'entre 10 et 20% son
chiffre d'affaires aujourd'hui elle est
allée à 40 50 % de chiffre d'affaires
c'est une solution qui est un acte noble
beaucoup comprennent alors vous vous
exercer à lyon le loyer moyen d'un hôtel
à lyon
c'est combien si l'hôtel et dans un
vieil immeuble et que le preneur
l'hôtelier a fait tous les travaux ça
sera entre 5 et 10% de son chiffre
d'affaires dans un contexte normal bien
sûr et si l'hôtelier a construit des
hôtels qui rembourse un emprunt murs et
fonds qui a fait énormément de qui est
que l'hôtel et est un hôtel qui a été
pris par le preneur clé en main et bien
c'est entre 10 et 20%
on a un commentaire de vie fille tient
qui avec nous sur youtube qui nous dit
pas la solution ce serait de loyer
gratuit en gros d'annuler les noix les
loyers d'annuler les loyers pendant
l'épidémie
aussi bien pour les restaurateurs que
pour les hôteliers vous partagez ce
commentaire je peux pas partager un
propos s'ils topix pas possible
les gens qui ont investi dans on est au
bout de la chaîne il ya des bailleurs
qui vivent de nos loyers alors est-ce
qu'ils sont tous des lentilles je peux
vous le dire parce que il ya que 16% des
les propriétaires d'hôtels en france qui
sont propriétaires de leurs murs
il y en a qu'on certainement les moyens
nous faire des faveurs et en a ils ont
fait énormément pour acheter le bâtiment
et le loup et donc ils ont aussi les ans
par angers c'est quoi la solution selon
vous à court terme pour le secteur de
l'hôtellerie
notamment pour les établissements ils
sont concernés par le couvre-feu alors
pour le loyer la solution elle est
d'apporter des facilités aux bailleurs
qui apporteront des réductions de loyer
à leur bonheur ça c'est clair
ok facilité fitial il ya tout un panel
de possibilités auprès de l'état et
quand on met des milliards pour sauver
air france a bien il ya 650 mille
chambres et 18000 hôtels en france qui
font le tissu est la première
destination touristique mondiale
il faut les sauver aussi donc il faut y
penser
et concernant les petits établissements
aujourd'hui dans une ville comme moi si
les propriétaires individuels ne laisse
pas les loyers et bien les restaurants
les bars ont changé d'endroit
plutôt que de faire des travaux
entretenir ils vont prendre leurs
chaises leur cuisine et vont prendre a
dit m quelqu'un qui aura perdu son
établissement et pendant sa place donc
je pense que les bailleurs ont intérêt à
faire les efforts soient déployés
merci beaucoup en tout cas laurent duc
d'avoir été avec nous est d'avoir
exprimé votre avis vos revendications et
d'avoir répondu aux questions de nos
internautes je rappelle que vous êtes
président de la branche hôtellerie du
syndicat umih merci beaucoup vous étiez
en direct de lyon d'avoir participé à
notre soirée spéciale on va retourner
dans les rues de la capitale
et je vais vous montrer tient ce qui se
passe sur sur twitter ce qu'on peu ce
qu'on est en train de constater sur
différentes publications une
manifestation contre le couvre-feu
manifestation évidemment non déclarés
qui est en train de se dérouler dans
paris je vais vous montrer quelques
quelques vidéos qui circulent alors
apparemment il y aurait au moins 100
personnes qui sont en train de marcher
dans des rues nous dit-on touristiques
de la capitale pour exprimer leur
opposition à ce couvre feu
on voit par exemple voilà des heures qui
sont taguées sur certains bâtiments
interventions en cours des forces de
l'ordre voilà des poubelles ont été
renversées a notamment les poubelles
destinées aux déchets recyclables on
voit ça en ce moment vous pouvez suivre
la situation évidemment sur lefigaro.fr
on va retourner dans les rues de paris
avec des images qui ont été captées un
petit peu plus tôt par nos partenaires
de la fp et dap et dans quelques
instants on retrouvera pour un deuxième
duplex le rédacteur en chef de figure
relève sylvain châtelain on va aller
dans le nord de la capitale on va voir
justement si bien c'est un petit peu
agitée comme ce qu'on vient de voir sur
les réseaux sociaux
brian 1 vous avez tiens vous avez
quelques questions sur l'hôtellerie
n'hésitez pas à vous renseigner sur le
site de lumière qui syndicats
représentatifs et donc on est heureux un
bien avoir reçu le président de la
branche hôtellerie à il ya quelques
instants
bonsoir à citrons bien mûr qui nous
rejoint sur notre chaîne twitch je lis
un petit commentaire de kieffer je suis
ok avec le fait que les restaurants les
cafés vont souffrir mais en étant
sérieux adultes dans notre réflexion la
faute à qui plutôt que de faire comme si
de rien était cet été faire la fête
aller en boîte faire des rassemblements
le long de la seine et bien il fallait
continuer à faire extrêmement attention
alors il faut pas se plaindre
aujourd'hui on récolte ce que l'on sème
ses autres avis les tranchées et en tout
cas on le prend en direct sur notre
chaîne switcher citron vous êtes bien
d'accord en tout cas avec ce message
rappelle qu'au cours des dernières 24
heures on compte plus de 32 mille
nouveaux cas supplémentaires
bonsoir ac scène qui nous a rejoints sur
lefigaro.fr bonsoir également a jar jar
binks qui est avec nous vous nous dites
les asiatiques ont su à très bien gérer
l'épidémie joie vous êtes quelques uns
aussi à nous demander des comparatifs
entre nations notamment entre nations
européennes ben là je vous renvoie aussi
à la homepage du figaro ou bien vous
aurez des articles de de comparaison qui
vont pouvoir vous vous éclairer avec
notamment le fic data qui est qui s'est
penché sur sur la question les jeunes
vont se réunir à domicile nous dit kris
kross dans le tchat sur lefigaro.fr va
justement le but c'est d'éviter un lait
les rassemblements à domicile c'est
notamment pour ça qu'il y a le couvre
feu
je voyais une internaute tout à l'heure
qui nous disait maintenant que l'on fera
des soirées entre amis il va falloir
prendre le pyjama et la brosse à dents
c'est ce que nous disait clara tout à
l'heure sur la page sur notre chaîne
youtube
des paroles mais pas beaucoup d'actes
nous dit de son côté romain on est
toujours sur notre chaîne youtube
bonsoir christian bonsoir il ya encore
du monde dehors à paris nous dit
christian alors là on vous diffuse des
images qui ont été tournées un petit peu
plus tôt c'est sûr que
proportionnellement à si on se fie à
l'interdiction totale de ceux de
circuler on peut considérer que si on
voit une poignée de personnes
effectivement du monde en tout cas je
vous rappelle t on va vouloir montrer
cette attestation de déplacement
dérogatoire que vous pouvez retrouver
sur lefigaro.fr si vous êtes concerné
par le couvre-feu et si vous avez un
déplacement à faire pour l'un de ses
motifs
vous pouvez la télécharger un vous tapez
attestation couvre-feu le figaro vous
allez tomber sur notre article
et on va pouvoir vous renvoyer vers
l'attestation papier ainsi que vers le
lien pour l'attestation smartphone c'est
marseille bébé nous dit qu'à la shiver
tiens vous avez vu je sais pas si vous
avez vu cette vidéo de jean luc
mélenchon justement qui s'est basé sur
ce type de jul du rappeur marseillais
jul jean luc mélenchon un député des
bouches-du-rhône à marseille pour
critiquer sur tik tok est bien le
couvre-feu une vidéo qu'on vous a
partagé sur lefigaro.fr hier en parlant
de marseille marseille qui mène toujours
1-0 contre bordeaux c'est de la ligue 1
marseille qui mène 1-0 grâce à un but de
florian thauvin à la 5e minute dites
nous dans le tchat
dites nous comment vous occuper ce soir
dans cette première soirée de couvre-feu
à marseille par exemple
aix-marseille 1 la métropole comment
vous occupez à paris je voyais des bons
conseils netflix tout à l'heure dites le
nous on est pour quelques minutes encore
dans ce live ensemble je salue crq ftd
bonjour je suis de droite mais à écouter
vous avez d'opinion vous voulez en tout
cas merci d'être avec nous sur notre
chaîne switch off you were still qui
nous fait plaisir d'être avec nous ce
soir
merci merci d'être là pierre tenue chic
bah écoute et merci à défaut de pouvoir
la porter dans un restaurant ce soir
j'apporte pour vous merci d'être là pop
x qui est là également
pas de couvre feu chez moi à bordeaux
justement il ya un article sur
lefigaro.fr qui explique bien pourquoi
bordeaux a entre guillemets échapper au
couvre feu alors que les données sont
pas forcément très très rassurante je
vous propose les amis qu'on prenne la
direction d'un quartier un petit peu
plus animée à l'heure actuelle ne serait
ce que parce qu'on voit un bus sur les
images qu'on va vous montrer
on retrouve sylvain châtelain rédacteur
en chef figure relève toujours dans le
xviiie arrondissement de paris alors
sylvain qu'est ce qui se passe autour de
vous tout à fait peur on n'est pas
rivaux l'avait vu ont toujours dans le
nord de paris
alors on s'est recentré on a surtout on
a surtout choisi de partir sur une
bouilloire un peu plus fréquentés et
vous pouvez sans devoir bien à moi ou
devant moi je roule seul devant il ya
encore beaucoup de circulation à cette
heure ci mon coup droit de sortir rooney
aussi beaucoup de transport en commun
vous pouvez le voir il ya très très peu
de monde sur les trottoirs sont ce mardi
de paris en tout cas sur son boulevard
de clichy
le couvre-feu a été vraiment respectée
on était là mais que ça arrive pas tous
de café qui nous disait que ses clients
semblaient avoir pris le consentement au
sérieux en tout cas le couvre vraiment
au sérieux que même s'il était parti à
la dernière minute ils étaient tous
partis après savoir ce qu'ils sont
vraiment entrés chez nous ça c'est le
rythme
on le saura plat en tout cas vous de
voir ici sur 100 sont pas venus ce qu'on
voit son enseignement des bus est bien
beau de montrer un panorama rapide voilà
du boulevard de ça vous évite d'avoir
trouvé ce contrat c'est normal mais il
faut savoir qu on entend mal ici voilà
on arrive de moulin rouge
moi je vous montre ce soit sur ses ondes
en temps normal
samedi soir il ya beaucoup plus de monde
notamment sur les trottoirs mais cette
période beaucoup plus de touristes parce
qu'on n'est pas très loin de mon art
voilà le moulin rouge
vous le voyez juste ici sur ce que les
images évidemment s'arrête on se bouge
avec julien et là vous pouvez voir tous
les restaurants sont fermés on voit ici
différentes enseignes au loin notamment
le starbucks tout est fermé mais
fast-food ici également qui est charmé
et quelques habitants qui arrange encore
leur scooter alors peut-être qu'ils sont
peut-être qu'ils sont comme moi les gens
qu'on voit ici avec dérogations on ne
peut pas dire allez vous difficile
d'interroger quelqu'un parce qu'en fait
la personne qui marche vraiment pardon
il marche vraiment autour de nous
uniquement des voitures des véhicules et
donc dans ce quartier traditionnellement
animé de paris qu'on voulait vous
montrer finalement nationale moi c'est
tout de même un peu de circulation
mais oui une question quand même sylvain
parce qu'on est on est sur un quartier
très touristique
pigalle 1
on voyait il ya quelques instants en
arpentant les réseaux sociaux que une
centaine de personnes au moins étaient
en train de se balader entre guillemets
c'est non c'est pas le vert mais en
train de manifester contre le couvre-feu
manifestations sauvages notamment sur
les sites touristiques
est-ce que vous avez croisé ces
manifestants sylvain est ce que vous
avez eu bruit de cette mobilisation
alors nous sur le boulevard des
patrouilles tout de même par ici ce qu'a
récemment première le premier véhicule
de police pour voir ce soit pour le
contrôle des personnes du respect du
couvre-feu pardon et donc vous me
demandiez si nous avions vu ce type de
rassemblement alors en arpentant le
boulevard de clichy donc dans ce
quartier de pigalle xviiie
arrondissement ne les avons pas nous les
avons pas du tout 3 et comme je le
disais nous on est plutôt là sur un
boulevard où il ya encore pas mal de
circulation beaucoup taxi beaucoup
transports en commun vous raconter
simplement autour de moi mais très très
peu de gens à pied et sans doute la
raison pour laquelle la voiture de
police que nous avons croisé un enfant
ne s'est pas arrêtée puisque ben il n'y
a pas grand monde à contrôler a pas
arrêté la voiture
même quand même quelques quelques
personnes tu rentres tu rentre chez elle
mais c'est vraiment gentil par rapport à
ce que ça d'habitude pour les pour les
gens qui me qui ne connaîtraient pas ce
ces quartiers sud endroits de la
capitale
c'est vraiment vraiment très très calme
plat les policiers vous avez croisé est
ce que leur camion leur véhicule roulait
au pas et ce qu'ils observaient
précisément où est ce qu'il y avait
quand même une forme de tranquillité
lors du passage des des forces de
l'ordre écoutez il roulait pas très vite
on va continuer julien dans le quartier
pour voir watine à ce qui va se passer a
gardé sa foule ici le quick on a encore
les livreurs aussi que sont la foi faut
il penser à sa livraison s'effectue au
travail donc l'obligation est notre
raison de certains responsables
bien sûr nous avons mis la police
une question des pieds bonjour oui oui
alors je vous les journalistes l'obtient
je vais vous demander de vous laisser du
coup autant au nord des actes sur le
site du figaro sur la question si vous
voulez on va couper l'image
effectivement si on va laisser le son si
c'est possible je vais demander à julien
en réalisation voilà si c'est facile de
laisser le son pour entendre et bien sûr
pour le voilà bon on va on va on va
rebasculer on va même coupé le son
puisque les policiers
évidemment en tant que journaliste on
est censé montrer l'exemple et obtempéré
donc ils ont demandé de couper la caméra
ces sons et images et on va obtempérer
en tout cas on va voir si sylvain
châtelain et bien écopent de 235 euros
damende normalement non puisqu'il est
journaliste et sa carte de presse et a
même l'attestation de l'employeur et
donc tout et tout est censé aller à
quelques commentaires
tiens je regarde ce zoom nous dit brian
je regarde des séries nous dit nous dit
mao ça bouge à gare du nord nous dit
blondin ça bouge pas mal dans le 93
notamment à bobigny vous nous dites ça
dans le tchad une question sur les
personnes handicapées je l' ai vu passer
sur youtube vous y répond je vous
réponds dans un instant on va revenir
voir sylvain châtelain si c'est possible
refaire un point j'ai l'impression que
le contrôle a été bref
oui pierre contrôle montrer notre
attestation est effectivement été rapide
vous nous demandiez si les policiers
étaient présents il veut ce n'est pas
pas trouvé que les red bull contient
constellé nous ont à nouveau contrôlé
nous faisons partie des marchés
boulevard de clichy et qu' il va vous
dire on est on est relativement bas l'an
passé 5e je vous parle forcément notre
attention
bon je sais ça fait des années si on
peut je sais pas si on a le bon sens
mais c'est pas possible un ouvrage
pourquoi se rendre à la gare du nord
voilà et puis on aura ce live justement
gare du nord pour voir effectivement les
gares parisiennes source d'animation en
temps normal en tout cas on va voir
comment ça se passe et on conclura
dessus je prends quelques quelques
messages confinement bien respecté en
belgique nous dit belle je résiste en
café restaurant fermé pour une période
de quatre semaines tiens vous aussi en
belgique vous avez un
couvre-feu de quatre semaines retrait
sur place de plats à emporter qui
restent possibles jusqu'à 22h les night
shops qui doivent fermer à 22h écouter
merci pour vos précisions
effectivement la belgique touchée elle
aussi par une deuxième vague et une
situation qui est jugé hors de contrôle
dans la capitale bruxelles
on vous souhaite évidemment bien du
courage un magnifique pays qu'est la
belgique et dans lequel j'ai eu la
chance de me rendre il y a quelques mois
merci en tout cas pour votre témoignage
ci comme notre ami belge résistants vous
nous écrivez d'un autre pays du une
ville en france qui n'est pas sous
couvre-feu dites nous comment se passe
votre soirée
est ce que comment vous vivez cette
situation jean jacques bourgeois qui
étaient avec nous sur twitter merci
d'être là merci max hoff bonsoir aussi à
case carreau on veut le son nous dit
amifontaine ah oui c'était tout à
l'ordre du contrôle de police alors non
on obéi à l'injonction des forces de
l'ordre et on coupe le son genre vous
êtes sur twitter nous dit i pod genre on
est sûr twitch effectivement tout à fait
on était même si vous fouillez dans nos
archives on sait qu'on est dans la perte
du g20 ne vous regardent et even 2019
on y était pour pour figaro relève
christian bonsoir christian sur la home
merci d'être avec nous merci d'être là
les taxis attendent beaucoup de temps
nous dit chris kraus effectivement avec
ce couvre feu
ils risquent d'attendre la clientèle
assez assez assez longtemps mais si on a
un train ou un avion qui part ou qui
arrivent après 21h ou élargissons avant
6 heures du matin on peut on peut on
peut circuler c'est ce qui a été
notamment expliquer expliquer l'autre
jour amsterdam 0 masques nous dit nous
dit chris kraus alors écoutez j'ai pas
les dernières données statistiques
concernant les pays bas un pays
frontalier évidemment de la belgique
écoutez on espère que tout soit zen du
côté des pays-bas
on se croirait sur une autre planète
vous nous dites en tout cas bon vous à
dire du côté d'amsterdam si c'est le cas
si vous êtes en tourisme on vous
souhaite un très bon séjour
je dis bonjour également à thierry qui
nous rejoint ainsi qu'à daniel sur la
home on va prendre quelques commentaires
sur bonsoir neil qui est avec nous sur
sur twitch j'arrive depuis deux secondes
et c'est déjà marre on va écouter on est
on est content de vous faire sourire
dites moi aussi comment vous passez
cette soirée que ce soit couvre-feu ou
pas pour vous je retourne sur twitch
prendre sur youtube pardon prendre
quelques quelques commentaires sa in aux
knicks qui est avec nous kirllos jims
aussi avons-nous dit jim de moi je serai
flics je mettrai pas une amende
bah on a interviewé tout à l'heure le
délégué national du syndicat unité sgp
police fo
et ils nous disaient voilà première
soirée on est effectivement dans de la
pédagogie on va pas je vais poser la
question je dis je suis consommateur
effectivement mon métro est un peu de
retard j'ai pris deux desserts au lieu
d'un au restaurant je suis sorti un peu
avec un petit peu de retard est ce
qu'elle 21h05 21h10 je pouvais me faire
contrôler oui mais est-ce que je vais
prendre une amende dès ce soir
il répond son nez dans la pédagogie au
moins au moins pour ce soir ça va pas
dire qu'on est dans le faites ce que
vous voulez faites n'importe quoi et
tout ira bien
en tout cas on a parlé de
une pédagogie je vais vous remonterez
les images qui sont en train de circuler
du côté
deux des réseaux sociaux avec bien cette
manifestation non-déclarée un sauvage à
plusieurs dizaines de personnes avec
apparemment les pour contester un le
couvre feu et l'intervention qui a été
nécessaire de la part des forces de
l'ordre on voit ces poubelles renversées
des images évidemment qui nous rappelle
les derniers soient pu voir
malheureusement lors des derniers
mouvements sociaux en france contre la
réforme des retraites notamment
on va retourner sur les images du côté
de paris bonsoir
jm qui est avec nous sur twitter
n'hésitez pas si vous avez une réaction
une question du tout quand vous occupez
ce soir il y a
vous et repère aussi une manifestation
anti couvre feu tient dans le chat alors
apparemment il aurait pas qu'à paris
qu'il ya des démobilisations en ce
moment batman est au chômage nous dit
master schnyder bat vous pouvez vous
aussi
effectivement on parlait de conseils
netflix tout à l'heure vous avez les
cinq saisons de gotham qui sont
disponibles sur sûre d'être flix
n'hésitez pas regardez regardez réponses
à toutes vos questions regardez la vidéo
sur l'état des urgences populaires leur
écoute et vous êtes libre de mettre des
des recommandations dans le chat dont
nous sommes libres aussi de les modérer
et de juger de juger la pertinence
dites nous si vous êtes concerné par le
couvre-feu en ile de france ou dans
l'une des huit métropoles 1 lille rouen
lyon grenoble saint-etienne aix
marseille montpellier toulouse
dites nous comment ça se passe du côté
de chez vous pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya
encore des gens pourquoi ils ne se font
pas arrêter nous dit et wayne sûr
notre chaîne youtube alors là les images
que vous voyez on sont des images qui
ont été tournées plus tôt vous voyez le
petit synthé qu'on vous a mis images
tournées et place de la bastille il ya
plus d'une heure maintenant vous voyez
le petit synthé qui permet de vous
repérer on va c'est pour ça qu'on va
conclure cela il bientôt d'ailleurs
puisque les images ne sont plus raccord
même si on vous met des indications avec
la situation va juste faire un petit
tour gare du nord avant avec 6 juin
châtelain et julien boudisseau du
figaro.fr pour regarder ce qu on va
refaire un pack vous un sylvain vous
êtes toujours sur la route de la gare du
nord vers la gare du nord a tiqué quitte
alors que nous a reconnu comme celle que
nous avons croisés la situation ici
identique en train de se rapprocher
légèrement le centre de paris de montrer
à quoi ressemble on peut le voir dans
pas mal de circulation est énormément
énormément via sur les légumes qui sont
20 sont toujours là on peut voir que la
question simple seuls pas de pas
d'autres verront pas ne veut pas de
patinoire quelques passants pourront
rentrer chez eux
nous on sait qu'au moins un parent qui
tarde que dix minutes durant
j'aime aller sereinement son équipier ce
n'est pas la police en avait plusieurs
plusieurs ambulances équipe à flâner
dans ce service qui sera bien évidemment
stationné devant arriver vers le
quartier de la gare du nord ou mars et
après un attentat au site
silva je vous interromps part nommé
d'après un internaute qui nous cite nos
confrères de bfm tv ce serait cette
manifestation plutôt du côté de la gare
de l'est qui est proche de la gare du
nord
on va voir ce qu'il en est alors qu'on
voit les pompiers en opération et les
pompiers qui soulève là vous êtes
désormais tout proche de la gare du nord
vous avez bonjour d'un habitant de nice
nous disent il bosse bah écoutez bonjour
du côté de nice nice pas concernés en
tout cas à l'heure actuelle par le
couvre-feu en tout cas on vous souhaite
une bonne soirée du côté des alpes
maritimes on va rester sur ces images de
sylvain châtelet on va regarder
l'arrivée du côté la gare du nord
sylvain alors du coup qu'est ce qui se
passe quelle est l'ambiance du côté de
la gare du nord l'ambiance pierre c'est
taxi service de livraison pouvant
vraiment très très actif lorsque jacques
c'est ce que jamais dans son pays et
donc on va garder un comblement
effectivement on le mange je ne bois pas
de rassemblement il ya quelques
personnes tout l'impression qu'on à
faire des gens qui attentivement des
confrères qui sont ici devant la gare du
nord et puis différentes personnes
simplement quand leur train donc non pas
de pas de mouvement particulier pierre
je ne sais pas quelles étaient vos aux
sources ou que vous êtes tout simplement
c'est une information qui nous venaient
du chat sur youtube mais vous voyez
comme ça on peut faire de la
vérification en direct et donc on est
quand même alors voilà on voit des
confrères qui l'interviewent des
voyageurs c'est notamment parce qu'ils
aient le le thalys qui arrivent et qui
part de la gare du nord pour aller à
bruxelles pour aller à anvers pour aller
à amsterdam ou encore à rotterdam aux
pays bas
merci beaucoup sylvain on va conclure
avec vous du coup un couvre-feu qui
al'air d'ores et déjà bien ancrée dans
les moeurs en juger par vos images
mais en tout cas dans le document que
nous avoir porté ce soir dans la
capitale mais ça veut dire rien de
vraiment constaté pas d'eau pas de
débordements pas de la part des gens qui
m'ont le prog l'aube allemand avec le
sourire même si farid le quartier nous
avons tout à l'heure évidemment
s'inquiétait pour la période de son
commerce et de son restaurant durant les
semaines et les mois qui arrivent mais
malgré tout beaucoup le sourire des gens
semblent vraiment prendre leur mal en
patience
maintenant bien sûr il faudra voir en
semaine puisque euros c'est le
poursuivant le consul manger intacte
dans le costume en poudre sont c'est
comme ça qu'on dit maintenant est amené
encore à a duré pour pour plusieurs
formes merci beaucoup si j'achète un
rédacteur en chef figure là ils vont
sera demain dans le cortège au
rassemblement place de la république à
paris à l'appel de charlie hebdo en
hommage à samuel ce professeur de
collège ce professeur d'histoire qui a
été sauvagement assassinée hier en
région parisienne à conflans sainte
honorine quelques commentaires pour
conclure pixman monsieur piles et il
faut préciser que si on en arrive au
couvre feu c'est que beaucoup de
français ne règle ne respectent pas les
règles d'hygiène pourtant simple à
écouter nous en tout cas on entreprises
on fait tout pour les respecter avec du
gel hydroalcoolique sur le plateau avec
des masques con mais dès qu'on sort du
plateau qu'on a désinfecté avant le live
et contre désinfecte eura après un nous
mêmes on fait en sorte de pouvoir
toujours venir sur notre lieu de travail
pour vous faire vivre en direct les
différentes actualités
merci à toutes et à tous d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir merci casse car ou est
rejetée ouarchiti citron bien mûres
kieffer 35 merci ce phénix d'avoir été
là sur twitch alors sur twitch bas c'est
assez simple je sais quoi vous souhaiter
un très bon event qui se déroule jusqu'à
demain soir cette cagnotte au profit
d'amnesty international ont salué
évidemment tous les streamer qui sont à
montpellier ou qu'ils sont
en duplex depuis depuis chez eux puisque
tous n'ont pas pu faire le déplacement
sur youtube merci à toutes et à tous
d'avoir été là également merci natas
alan merci cricri bryan bryan qui dit qu
il était serveur en resto en tout cas on
vous donne rendez vous demain pour ce
rassemblement place de la république je
vous le disais 15 heures on prendra
l'antenne un tout petit peu avant pour
bien prendre le pouls au coeur de la
capitale et on va voir aussi comment se
conjuguent et bien cette ce
rassemblement et la crise sanitaire
puisque on le rappelle un pari
évidemment est en alerte maximale merci
mathieu d'avoir été avec nous sur
lefigaro.fr merci à il a french jar jar
binks jean-paul évidemment sur la home
aussi on vous donne rendez vous demain
aux alentours de 15 heures jean paul ii
paris est la capitale du tourisme on
s'arrêtera sur votre commentaire plein
d'optimisme on espère évidemment revoir
les touristes français bien sûr et
étrangers le plus rapidement possible ce
qui signifiera des indicateurs au beau
fixe entre guillemets merci à toutes et
à tous merci à julien d'avoir réalisé ce
direct et à julie d'avoir animé et
enrichit les différents chat très bonne
soirée à toutes et à tous sous couvre
feu
ou pas d'ailleurs